puoi iniziare video presentandoti con la
sigla di peppa pig spa vi è questo il
mio fratellino abidjan detto chi cazzo
sei bella tutti ragazzi e femminucce
questo nuovo video sono qua vj e non ho
ancora capito perché in ogni caso il
video faccio così ed oggi siamo in un
nuovo blog come al solito ragazzi volevo
iniziare con la parte della settimana e
volevo fare una precisazione alla
relazione la farà per la settimana è
stata vinta da alessandra che ha fatto
questo capolavoro è la quale faccio i
miei complimenti perché disegna
benissimo direi impazzare le news che
sono importantissime questa settimana
prima di tutto ragazzi volevo cominciare
ovviamente ringraziandovi per il
traguardo incredibile che è stato
raggiunto
ovvero 300 mila iscritti ma che cazzo
succede
siete fantastici e vi meritate qualsiasi
cazzo di cosa quindi non venitemi a dire
favi prenditela comoda perché quando
vedo tutto questo supporto che è che mi
lasciate sotto ogni video sono i
commenti eccetera e tenetevi pronti
ragazzi molti di voi lo sanno perché lo
avevo anche detto già in precedenza farò
non uno ma ben tre speciali e
sperimentare uno speciale ogni 100mila
iscritti ragazzi perché ve li meritate
tantissimo e chiedo scusa ragazzi perché
in teoria avevo detto che sarebbe dovuto
uscire entro oggi non l'avevo assicurato
ma avevo detto che sarebbe dovuto uscire
entro oggi il primo dei tre speciali è
però il primo di tre speciali e quello
più lungo perché ci sto lavorando da
tantissimi i ragazzi non credo che
uscirà domani
uno di questi giorni della settimana
aspettatevelo lo dirò la sera prima su
facebook ovviamente va uno dei giorni di
questa settimana che arriva uno
qualsiasi a caso al primo dei tre
speciali quindi aspettatevelo
sicuramente perché sarà epico ve lo
garantisco invece lo speciale successivo
dovrebbe uscire il sabato prossimo è
quello dopo ancora sabato dopo ancora
quindi ragazzi preparatevi perché avrete
due settimane incredibili e ve lo
garantisco sarà fantastico e come ultima
cosa ragazzi giusto per buttare un po di
carne al fuoco perché mi piace a tenerci
sulle spine e che ne direste se
registrarsi un video in live e con
questo ragazzi spero di avervi messo
abbastanza curiosità e direi che
possiamo passare allo scatto
taggia dei pacchi ragazzi volevo fare
una cosa un po particolare oggi volevo
offrire sti tre pacchi qui che sono
aperti sono più piccoli di più volevo
aprire questi due fatti qui che sono
questo sembra un pacco di natale non
idea di che cosa sia ma in cartotto così
mi fa impazzire come ultima cosa ragazzi
dovete spiegarmi che cazzo e questo mi
avete inviato è un binocolo o è un dildo
un po grosso agnelli che cazzo sia
ragazzi ma lo apro per ultimo perché
sono questo prima di vedere che cosa
sono gli altri facciamo velocemente ai
più piccoli che sono tanto veloci da
aprile cioè ci metto pochissimo let's go
round nettare degli dei
caramelle caramelle non mi sa peccatore
anche con una
anche se con qualche sorgendo man o dio
non ci posso credere
altre chiara melle con questa mise un
prezzo tante ragazze non ho mai capito
come cazzo si mangiano si cosi a quello
che cos'è sta roba
una pallina magica lune cagnoli oddio
sono tempo c'è una tenerissimi un numero
di diabolik non so questo me lo metto
nella co elettorato è bellissimo è tutto
nuovo
c'è mio dio non è toccato fanta questo
me lo metto nella collezione grazie
mille e come ultimo c'è questo tizio
ragazzi sembra una bambola voodoo tipo
che se lo tocco qualcosa succede a
qualcuno da qualche parte nel mondo è
con questo ragazzi ha concluso con
infatti più piccoli e direi di passare a
quelli un po più grandi sono curioso di
sapere che cazzo è sta roba che sembra
un pacco di natale
leggiamo che diavolo dentro ragazzi mi
sta incuriosendo un casinò sta cosa ve
lo dico subito
ok si è aperto non è da lì che cazzo
cos'è sta roba
bello scottex con scritto po vj
giustamente spero non sia carta da culla
un toast tra l'altro mangiato o degli
occhiali che questi sono
poi ci sono delle praline che caz ta
cosa bellissima
vi ringrazio tantissimo per il parco e
trento ragazzi sono pieno di dolci cazzo
e livelli passare io divento mezzo nel
prossimo video sappiatelo questo il mio
piatto ragazzi madonna quanto a roma ci
ha detto
[Musica]
ho appena trovato il mio scopo nella
vita
[Musica]
e dopo di questo ragazzi braccialetto
che ho scritto lorenzo avrebbe
bellissimo tratto fatto che sia rosa
braccialetto questo ragazzino mento
direttamente non fate commenti perché
rosa perché bellissimo come ultimo
ragazzi siamo arrivati al mega al mega
binocolo credo che sia perché se no non
me lo spiego
voglio un mega barattolo di pringles
ragazzi a non ha idea di che cazzo se a
viggiù roma si sta apatico le pringles
quindi magari mi trovo le patatine che
cazzo ne è una cosa attivo addio
oddio c'è qualcosa al fondo aspettato il
secondo al volo che caffè roma a ragazzi
sono così non lo guardo per ultimo prima
voglio vedere che cosa cazzo è è una
cosa fottutamente enorme
io non ci voglio credere è la più grande
fatica abbia mai ricevuto fino a ragazzi
enorme non ho mai ricevuto la fonati
così grossa aspettate che mi metto in
una posizione comoda e vi faccio vedere
c'è di tutto abbiamo spada danza un
simulator
ringrazio fantastico e sul retro abbiamo
ovvio zio ecco i giochi più belli che è
completato dai tre più grandi fan
martina david alessandra federica
francesco grandissimi ragazzi aspettate
che sto morendo e fatto che è talmente
grosso che potrei usare l'occhio come
coperta comunque è epico ragazzi
fantastico grazie infinite è veramente
la fan art più grande che abbia mai
ricevuto fino adesso i ragazzi
complimentoni perché epica crini ragazzi
grazie di cuore a tutti direi che
possiamo passare risponde prima domanda
ragazzi falli risponde come ti è venuta
l'idea di finire i video con il
telecomando ragazzi in teoria questa non
è stata un'idea che
c'è che avevo sin dall'inizio è un'idea
che mi è venuta in mente dopo perché
volevo trovare una chiusura epica per il
canale dato che si chiamava fa vj tv
quindi televisione è la prima volta
ragazzi mi è venuto in mente proprio
così per caso ho preso un telecomando
eletto ciao ragazzi cieli al prossimo
vinto ben e poi da lì è partita la cosa
fa vi chiudi prossimo vinto con il
telecomando chiude anche il prossimo e
siamo andati avanti così e alla fine è
diventato la mia chiusura marmi ha
chiuso la standard in poche parole a mpc
fido fa vi risponde non cercare fa vj e
su google
federico fg fa vi risponde cosa
succederebbe se tu diventassi l'omino di
aimo nappi the gun allora in realtà e ai
wanna be the guy non hai wanna be the
gun degan significa io voglio essere
l'arma cioè non ha senso che io voglio
essere una
ma risponde search vescovo di
costantinopoli si potesse this
arcivescovo di dolci vescovi ma cosa
cazzo c'è scritto se l'arcivescovo di
costantinopoli si volesse di darci besco
bis con mogol scusarci vescovi scones ma
porca di quella punta pisa arcivescovi
scostanti localizzare gli arcivescovi
costantino polizze resti perthes
arcivescovi scostante l'arcivescono di
costantinopoli si volesse this
arcivescovi costantinopoli dare gli
arcivescovi scostanti napoli testi per
these are cives costantinopoli zone lui
il lancio la sfida prova a fare un gioco
horror o un giorno da incazzatura
estrema tipo che mario senza dire
nemmeno una parolaccia è troppo forte
con incassi ma voglio vedere se ci
riesci ti stimo oggi ai ragazzi credono
veramente che non riesca a contenermi a
figuriamoci non spiccica era una
parolaccia manco a morire [ __ ] ma
veroni porta a porta di quella puzza
va bè ragazzi ieri che possono includere
qui il video ricordatevi che lo speciale
comunque esso in settimana quindi da un
momento all'altro aspettatevelo perché
vi sbuca così all'improvviso e tenetevi
pronti perchè sarà epico con che ragazzi
come sono in tu sei lì dove è piaciuto
lasciato un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come non i video
trovate nella descrizione riscritti
scrivetevi noi ci vediamo un prossimo
video per ragazzi